Jim Trotter here on the show how are you
Jim I'm great rich how you doing I'm
doing better for talking to you I
appreciate you you calling in how how is
this new six-point policy sitting with
NFL players best you can tell so far all
right yes still early but I think the
fact that that the league has now gotten
out of the business of saying it's going
to discipline our fine players for
demonstrating sits better with them than
the alternative because when it was
floated yesterday that players might be
penalized or fined by the league if they
demonstrated during the anthem I can
tell you that I spoke to players last
night including some high profile who
were upset about that and said that it
would create an issue further wedge
between the league and the players so to
do it this way I think is workable and
and look rich the reality is with this
quote-unquote new policy is that it's
not dramatically different from the from
the policy that was in place and what
was taking last year there were teams
that allowed their players to stay in
the locker room if they chose to during
the anthem last year and that is what
they're putting in formal writing this
year the only significant difference now
is the league is no longer the one that
will be disciplining players if they
demonstrate it's now up to the team and
that's significant from the standpoint
because it allows the relationship
between the league and the players to
continue to grow particularly with this
new social justice initiative well so
let's take it one step at a time then
what is the so it would be up to the
team to determine how expensive a fine
would be if a player decides to come out
and sit on the bench during the national
anthem or take a knee or and then you
know so that let's take that one step at
a time is that what it would being good
correct so the league if a player were
to demonstrate during the anthem rather
than stay in the locker room the league
can find the team for that now the team
if it so chooses can take action against
the player now what does that mean we
don't know at this point a team may
choose not to take action a team may
choose to find a player for what it
considers to be quote unquote
conduct detrimental is how it was
explained to me but there are provisions
under the CBA that deal with conduct
detrimental so there's still a lot of
things that are we understand in theory
but in practice they still have to be
determined because we've not seen it so
yes if a player were to demonstrate it
would be up to the team to choose
whether or not it wants to discipline or
find that player and at this point we do
not know what those fines are what that
discipline could be and what about asked
that specifically of Jerry Jones by the
way okay I said to him if one of your
players were to take a knee what would
you do and he said I'm not going to deal
in conjecture so he would not answer a
question what about the fine program or
schedule if you will from the league to
the teams is that been dishonorable no
it has not at least as from the folks
that we have talked to that I have
talked to it has not been decided yet it
could be a tiered fine but at this point
it has not been decided now from what
one league official said to me you know
it could go we know that league fines
can go all the way up to a half million
dollars or what it may be I don't think
anyone's expecting that but at this
point it has not been been definitively
decided what that fund would be and Jim
Trotter and if a media group longtime
Sports Illustrated in ESPN reporter here
on the Rich Eisen show what about what
constitutes disrespect Jim you know what
rich to be as Frank as I can be about it
it sounds like it's the same thing as
defining what sonography is it's in the
eye of the beholder
you know Commissioner Goodell said at
his press conference you know our fans
know it when they see it well everyone
has a different interpretation of that
some people find it offensive when
players kneel some don't so again it
depends it's in the eye of the beholder
now what the league will do I assume
based on conversations I have had is
that they will put in writing what they
expect of their players when they are on
the sidelines so for instance does that
mean as what's what was currently in the
game operations manual where you're
supposed to stand with your helmet I
believe in your left hand and your your
hand over your heart is that going to be
formal now that that's what every player
must-do we don't know at this point so
the league still has to determine that
but I think for clarity sake it would
behoove the league to come out with
something that definitively says what is
expected of a player on a sideline let
me give you for instance sure so if if a
player were to kneel during the anthem
in prayer not in protest but in prayer
is that acceptable the likely answer is
no if a player who is a Muslim face or
to stand during the anthem with his
hands in front of his face he's standing
during the anthem but his hands are in
front of his face is that okay well you
may say yes so then the question becomes
are you is discriminating against one
faith as opposed to another it's a
question that you have to think about
for down the road another thing is it
okay to raise a fist during the anthem
we have not gotten a definitive answer
on that yet you know whether or not it's
okay to raise it during the entire
anthem or at the end there are still
things that have to be worked out here
so that was the danger of having words a
word like disrespect in there because
that means different things to different
people so not only do we not know what
disrespect is or what the fine schedule
would be but there's a possibility here
that a player could wind up being fined
heavily by a team owner that interprets
disrespect one way and another team
owner might just say to the NFL find me
I don't care my players want to do it
and that's I stand behind them that
that's all still possible in the NFL
yeah it's absolutely possible it's left
up to the teams now to decide whether or
not they will find players if they
demonstrate but if the league finds a
team though Jim isn't that technically
finding the players by saying that they
that they're not they're not they're not
taking money out of the players pocket
but what we are saying is that is that
is that they still disagree with it and
that might create an issue between the
players and the league despite what you
the intent is to have the relationship
grow is know in a literal sense what
you're saying is absolutely right the
league is not taking money out of the
players pocket which is as you know very
important to a player sure but it is
taking it out of the team's pocket if it
chooses to find them that's the other
thing it says they can find a team will
they find a team we won't know until we
get to that situation so there's still
you know there's a lot of gray here but
the owners felt that they had to do
something and as I understand it when
they broke yesterday there were a group
of roughly nine to ten owners who felt
that they wanted to keep the status quo
in part because they felt that they had
gone through the roughest part of this
that they're doing work with their
players in terms of the social justice
initiative and the things that they are
doing off the field as well to confront
these issues that are important to the
players and so they felt why do we want
to now reignite this when we're only
talking about a handful of players who
were actually demonstrating but the
other thing is there was another group
of owners as I was told a handful or so
who were more adamant that they wanted a
strong policy in place and they wanted
the teams to have control over that and
then the rest of the owners I was told
wanted some sort of change but didn't
quite know what and so when you look at
the sheer numbers what it was saying is
that you had roughly 22 or so owners and
again I'm using rough numbers but you
had roughly 22 owners who were saying we
want some sort of change and so then it
became for the vet to happen the league
had to figure out a way what what could
we come up with it would be palatable to
the owners who were saying no change
that I don't want to have to go back to
my players who I'd I have told that I
support you and what you're doing but
now we're changing this and we're going
we're going to discipline you if you
demonstrate and so there was this sort
of compromise if you will that they
would do it this way and that sort of
got everybody over to to the same pace
now Jed York of the 49ers did abstain
and he said in part it was because he
felt the players should have been more
involved in this process that they
should have been part of the discussion
and that he believes that they were
doing good work
are doing good work and that they were
moving forward and he's all about
progress you know and not necessarily
punishment so he abstained from the vote
but other than him Jerry Jones and
others were all saying that the owners
all got on the same page and now there
appears to be some clarity and some
consistency you know it's interesting
Jim because Jed York also said that he
texted Richard Sherman from inside the
meeting to give him a heads-up as to
what was coming down the pike and that's
exactly what we're I guess this brings
it all full circle in a way Jim is that
each individual team has its own market
and its own fan base it has a toleration
level for the lack of better phrase or
an in toleration level for the lack of
better phrase for this very subject and
in terms of wanting to win football
games the most if you will Lok team in
the NFL won at all last year and if this
helps you win football games by letting
the players speak their minds in any way
shape or form then a team's gonna go
ahead and do that and the other teams
might not and and it you know so I guess
when it all comes down to it this social
initiative plan is is the positive
moving forward aspect of it what what is
it best you can tell well look this is
the thing that in my opinion folks don't
talk about enough you know everyone
wants to focus on on the demonstrations
and again it was only a handful of
players that we're talking about here by
the end of the year and and they were
not protesting again I'm repeating
myself here you know at the expense of
folks who know me but they weren't
protesting the ants and they weren't
protesting the military they weren't
protesting law enforcement they were
protesting and adjustment and injustice
that they see in the community and they
wanted to shine a light on it now having
said that the thing that folks don't
recognize enough is the real work that
these players are doing in their
communities to try and make positive
change so for instance with the players
coalition one of the pillars of the
players coalition is criminal justice
reform so you say well what are they out
doing well you know a week or so ago I
went up to the the Bay Area in
California and they're holding sort of
these public forums where they're
interviewing district attorney
candidates
before the public why because one of the
quickest and most efficient ways to deal
with criminal justice reform is on the
local level and district attorneys have
so much power so they're doing that you
say why are they having an impact
well you look in Philadelphia and they
lobbied hard the coalition members
lobbied hard for the clean nate's clean
slate act that got passed you look at
Massachusetts where the the players
coalition wants to focus on juvenile
sentencing and in Massachusetts a bill
was passed through the house or now the
age for juvenile sentencing is being
increased or raised so there are areas
where they are having a real impact but
the public doesn't want to focus on that
and I think the NFL is smart and saying
we feel these these issues are important
we want to continue to work with our
players on that we want to show them
that we're doing the right thing that we
do support them not only in money but
you have owners who have been out you
know doing these things some of the more
progressive owners in this when you talk
about it you talk about a Jed York you
talk about a Michael Bidwell who's been
really supportive Arthur Blank shad Kahn
Stephen Ross Jeffrey Lurie you can go
down the list who these guys say this
these issues that these players are
fighting for are very important to us
and we do support them on this we also
understand that there is a business
element to this in terms of how some
fans feel and we also want to be
respectful of that well then I guess the
last one for you then Jim is is there a
group of players who based on what you
just said who are who would basically
not sit knowing that it conflates the
issue for people that will never
understand why they're sitting or
kneeling and taking away the attention
of all that good work that you're
talking about that if you posted all the
focus on that that this is where the
social injustice correction comes from
as opposed to kneeling is there is that
there's some sort of movement there that
that that the kneeling kind of run its
course if you will you know well that
was the feeling of did I mean Jed felt
that it had run its course again when
you look at the end of last season there
were only a handful of players who were
kneeling and so he
felt that they were they were buying
that and I go back to the words of dr.
Harry Edwards it was a piece I wrote at
the end of last season where dr. Harry
Edwards the renowned sports psychologist
and and an activist it said movements
are fleeting and he talked about back in
the 68 Olympics where he was part of the
group that you know when John Carlos and
Tommie Smith race there at the club fist
and dr. Harry Evers was part of that he
said after a while that died and then he
talked about the Occupy Wall Street
movement and he said how that died and
then he pointed to things like black
lives matter or the me to movement those
sorts of things how they have a finite
shelf life if you will and he said even
with these anthem demonstrations that
was going to pass in time and so by
changing the anthem protocols now you
sort of reignite the fire there or
discussion in the debate and the feeling
among some was that this was dying so to
answer your question do I think that
more players now or there will be
players now who will still continue to
try and press this issue and will
demonstrate you can never say never and
that's the reality reality of it and
nothing that you do was going to stop
that short of keeping the players in the
locker room all players in the locker
room during the national anthem and the
elder simply did not feel that that was
the right course of action great chat
Jim's thrilled you're part of the NFL
media group truly rich thanks for having
me
you bet that'll be the first of many
times as a member of the NFL Media Group
Jim Trotter here on the Richardson show
so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience